what's up taste buddies i am hitting the
road to do stand-up comedy finally i
haven't been out in a while all tickets
available at
savilecanocomedy.com right now i will be
in
uh fort lauderdale to dania uh improv uh
november 12th through the 14th i will be
in the west palm beach improv uh
december 4th and 5th i will be
uh at in boston in medford at the cheval
year i don't know if i'm saying that
right theater december 10th boston come
out you always come out big and then i'm
really excited about this one the
borgata in atlantic city new jersey i
performed there like so many times with
the guys never solo first one that's
gonna be a lot of fun uh where else we
going with this the week between
christmas and new year's eve december 26
dallas december 27 san antonio december
28th sugarland december 29th st louis
missouri december 30th column columbus
ohio and new year's eve in cincinnati
ohio all co-headlining with chrissy d
all tickets savile kennel comedy.com
right now
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking taste buds hey taste buddies
welcome to t-a-s-t-e
i'm joe i'm sal here we are
tuck your thing in please
right from the get right from the get i
don't wanna i don't wanna i don't wanna
register complaints from the get you got
a lot of things i like things to be in
order it's
okay you know when you lean forward that
comes out you see the mattress on it no
i know it's an eyesore no it's an
eyesore but speaking of eyesores
speaking our stories christa stefano was
just here
uh we are
you guys when you do t hey babe yeah
what is the time issue what happens
nothing what do you mean what happens i
got two reps in the bank you started at
11 no no we didn't started like 11
40. because chrissy hipps was late
wasn't he no pimpy hit traffic pimpy hit
traffic oh he we we threw chris right
under the bus i said chris was late i
was giving chris [ __ ] he goes yeah he
was well i knew you were sending him a
voice memo and i just wanted to bother
him
oh you know what pip i respect it i like
that move that's a nice evil move i was
going to see her trash chris that's good
stuff i like it i like it came early to
do yoga no joke anyway we got we we got
in
right yeah and then i was like because i
gotta i gotta leave at some point today
and i said all right i got a thing you
guys hosed me again he left early you
gotta leave early i have to do
32 ads alone no no 16 ads alone that's
not that bad 32 was bad 16's not bad
okay
the uh no it sucks
but it's it's better than 32. i feel for
you
i think i love but what i was going to
make fun of was the moving
as we start later trying to get started
so i was like i'm like okay we just got
to move it sounds like
fix please fix your mic thing please
tuck this i don't like living this way
i live i live with terrible ocd
i i swear to you i want to get
hypnotized
swear to god i i've looked into it yeah
yeah really i i do i really want to get
hypnotized okay all right have you been
hypnotized yeah
let's talk about in a moment okay we
will um uh and you you will hear me on
the episode of hey babe calling up to
chris and saying that the epis that that
tv show deck that not dexter uh derek
stinks you don't like it he likes it and
then he called me your opener which hurt
i don't know where that came from that
was hurtful yeah i know in his defense i
might open for you
he doesn't even know that
no i know i'm saying though yeah you
gotta let me know about those i did
i let you i said let me know if i can do
the one that i'm asking about okay okay
we'll talk about nafta okay all right
all right but you said you might have a
guy already yeah yeah you guys plan
things on air all the time
i might see out there with sal folks
this is good
anyway look here's the show uh taste
buds today the battle is captain crunch
breweries versus honey nut cheerios and
you're wondering how could you be
possibly arguing captain crunch berries
when that's
you and sal's favorite cereal joe well
it's because we have our first guest
ever ever
here is the table where that guest will
be sitting
uh and there are some things on this
table that the guests will be utilizing
wow in addition to challenging us as a
team this is going to be a real
humdinger we're breaking all sorts of
formula rules here all sorts of fun
we're teaming up for the first time ever
and we're taking on a noob we have 50
fights under our belt yeah this is like
tyson fighting jake paul yeah yeah you
know what i mean but with holyfield
with holyfield
holyfield tyson and holyfield fighting
jake paul exactly i'm sorry i bit your
ear here's your ear back yes now let's
go fight so this is tremendous we don't
even know how this is going to go this
won't count toward the record books
but uh let's bring out jake paul
ladies and gentlemen the first ever
guest on taste buds you know from his
podcast skeptic tank
ari
shafir
i'll be jake paul i don't give a i don't
give a crap
how you doing they probably for a second
thought jake paul was
which wouldn't have been that weird
imagine jake paul was waiting in my
bathroom those four minutes that would
have been great i know
yeah that would have been great
promoting the hell out of that bathroom
um all right guys thank you glad to be
here glad to have you in studio yeah
i love dark comedy really yeah yeah
swear you're not making a spelling bee
yeah oh it's great oh that's so funny
chris yeah okay yeah um uh yeah in
studio i'm so glad i was i was
a little known fact i was around when
you guys had the first argument
that gave birth to the popular podcast
uh taste buds yes you post you made the
video the day we argued well the first
one ever was on the cruise we were
arguing oreo was chips ahoy but it went
away and then the day we said we should
make this into a podcast we were away
and we were arguing cinnamon raisin
bagel versus everything because we had
both yeah we had both and uh and we were
arguing both and then
yeah and already in fact
during the period be in between we
should do a podcast and what are we
going to call it that six hour stretch
is when ari made a video
and said which would you choose cinnamon
raisin or everything having a way in the
video yeah that's right that's right and
then you repost that video
a year on the year anniversary and you
said the birth of taste buds and i think
everybody thought you were being like
like a smart ass like i invented 10 but
it's like no that literally was the
birth of taste buds yeah then you start
the podcast later i was like yeah
yeah
so so i thought you left a lot on the
table on that on that um cinnamon raisin
oh that's cool yeah all right i was
listening to it in ecuador driving down
a country road in ecuador laughing my
ass off but going like the one thing you
didn't say is the everything babylon has
everything except cinnamon and raisin
it's a completely different right it
doesn't envelop how did every other how
dare they call it everything because
it's not yeah right well yeah
that's a systematic
dismantling cinnamon and raisin was
included in the everything it's also
disgusting to call yourself everything
when you know you're not everything well
yeah i mean there's a there's other
things that aren't in it like ketchup
and you uh everything there's no parsley
in the everything everything is you all
right uh i remember that you called you
you zoomed us from pakistan where the
[ __ ] yeah it was pakistan
the northern region it's it's not under
dispute you said we started listening to
the podcast out here and it's like
hanging out with you yeah it was you
left for five months and just six months
you went off for six months and you just
went to the jungle and you just you just
walked around
yeah
i just like worked down like four is
gone with running you you uh you have
probably seen more of the world than
most people i know i think my dog has
probably seen more of the world than
most of my friends yeah that's true
yeah yeah
shut up bandit
bandit shout out bandit ari's an
interesting guy because
he
he's one of the guys that chastised me
into the halloween parade you tipped me
over the top on the list i will say we
fall in line a lot with group activities
and fun activities yeah you and me yeah
yeah yeah for sure you gotta go for it
tipped me you pushed the final thing
where i was like all right this sounds
fun i'll do it but before that ari
really really was giving me [ __ ] about
why would you not enjoy new york
meanwhile this guy goes to the amazon
for six months out of the year he
abandons new york when the going gets
tough
right but you think when i'm in the
amazon i'm not going to go to the
mosquito festival
he's going everywhere he's when he was
out there i bet you he went to the main
amazon warehouse out there
and let it be known derosa trashed you
two on bonfire over this halloween
parade yeah you heard he got mad at me
about that because i
i gave away the initial uh
so yeah yeah
we were hanging we always thought you're
going to come on once and finally you're
going to come on and we said this will
be perfect because there's things that
we can battle because we agree on a few
of them we agree on chocolate pudding
versus jello we agree on pudding
we agree always the other one joey
um um
well it's i don't want to give it away
okay not potentially an upcoming battle
we're just talking about i don't know so
anyway so we decided that we would team
up for captain crunch for the first time
ever this is more of an exhibition
you're gonna we asked you you were
allowed to pick whatever one you wanted
to battle us yeah you came to the table
with honey nut cheerios honey nut cheers
which i actually think
was a really really smart pick
do you yeah because i thought you were
gonna go
like
the route of like a lucky charms or
something yeah well we did for loose but
like i thought you would do fruit i
thought you're gonna go fruit sugar like
that but i will tell you honey nut
cheers i believe when we read that last
episode i believe
they might be the number one selling
cereal ever it's gotta be cheerios
cherry no honey nut beats it up not ever
it was started
30 years before first years before i'm
telling you right now honey nut cheers
outsells every cheerio it's great so
it's the accessible sugar syrup i also
think that
it's good because the people who don't
go for the sugary type cereals will go
for cheerios
so i think this is going to be a really
interesting matchup there is a false
narrative sense of there's a false sense
of nutrition with cheerios for some
reason yeah i don't know why it is like
like eating kale yeah yeah it's not it's
just cardboard like the rest of them
yeah it was their ad campaigns when we
were growing up it was like that was the
healthy cereal for kids and then honey
nut cheerios was like what if cheers had
flavor yeah then you're like yeah and
you think you're eating a s it's got the
word nut yeah honey never sounds bad no
it sounds healthy
honey yeah it does sound like vegetables
i love honey cheerios i love regular
cheerios you see children eat them just
snacking on them yeah but one of those
for your sake you you should hope that
infants are voting as well i hope they
are they're not even exposed to what you
guys are doing if an infant puts the
captain crunch down they'll slice the
trachea open yeah the cheerios are the
only ones they could actually eat now
the captain would have
tons of lawsuits on
the captain would be defrocked we uh
now now in addition to the challenge of
ari having to take on the taste buds
as a team uphill battle
uh i also agreed
to do i had a i had a uh i did a show
the other shout out to the fan
i'm sorry i don't remember your name but
she gave me a bag with some gifts and in
the gift bag was the infamous
ghost pepper chip well that is so hard
to find there's a price tag on that
thing look at that fifteen dollars
no way i think they were one scout
because you can't get them because
everyone bought it to do the challenge
so i want you to read the warning okay
but i also well actually read the
warning and then i'll explain why right
out of the gates i'll just tell you i've
heard of these challenges before eating
hot foods and and and i've i grew up on
spicy food so none of this will be a
problem but it got to the point where i
was like you spray food and people like
well then drink this tabasco straight
and i'm like i'm not here for your
entertainment but then i would do it and
it's like no it's spicy but tabasco but
i i ever watch hot ones they show the
scoville ratings of the heat
very good yeah so tabasco is like
like 300
it's like okay look at me look at my
face
tabasco sauce is somewhere like around a
thousand yeah that i think that is
somewhere around a couple of million
okay so ghost pepper is 417 times hotter
than the mildest jalapeno yeah it's
pretty goddamn hot dude opinions are for
babies wait read the read the warning on
the back
do not eat if you're a sensitive warning
big warning
ghost peppers have been made into
military great smoke
all right so juice
those mustards
yeah that's true that is [ __ ]
do not eat if you're sensitive to spicy
foods or allergic to peppers i'm not
night shades or capsaicin nightshades
eggplant
something like that wow that's a
nightshade isn't that what they got the
uh the professor and uh in a nightmare
before christmas didn't they get him
with deadly nightshade really yeah with
that girl i don't remember this i don't
remember nightchurch
or are pregnant or have any medical
conditions are you pregnant no i do
bleed anally a lot yeah
i've seen it that means you're not
so so i i tell i think we're on a group
thread maybe and there's a nat in here
that i swear to god you texted me pimp
you texted the no press thread first
yeah
and then i pray tell you how does it get
to him saying i'll do it i was walking
with yeah yes yes we were walking from
the stand to the cellar because we had
spots we were on the same shows that
same night
we were walking down to the in fact
that's that we walked into the cellar
and the girl was there at sitting alone
at the table and she's like oh my god
you're generosa i'm such a and she was
like talking i was like yeah hi it's
very nice to meet you whatever and then
you walked in you were like what's up
what do you want to do and she was like
oh oh my god like she couldn't take how
many comics she liked
and then ari and i just walked out
anyway we were nice though like red
skelton walked in yeah yeah uh yeah red
skelton records she's like red skelton
so anyway i was walking with ari when
you were texting us and saying like
somebody gave me this chip
they said they want me to eat it on one
of the podcasts i'm not doing it will
anybody else do it
pimp said winner loser of taste buds has
to do it i can't do it i would rush to
the hospital yeah i go guys i don't
think i could do it either i honestly
think it'll it'll it'll level me
um like in an
almost hospital way and then i said i'm
with ari hold on and i asked him you
would eat this right and he's like
i don't care
and
yeah to up the challenge it's the
brazenness of it though it's crazy i saw
him once eat having a bag of habanero
tortilla corn tortilla chips yeah
i ate one i was sweating uncontrollably
at from one good sweat he was eating
them like they were like they were m m's
and he was pouring sweat and i was like
uh how hot is it he's like it's really
hot it's really hot but he wasn't
breaking his stairs his gaze was not
breaking habaneros are probably five
percent or ten percent of the heat of
ghost peppers if i remember right but i
i ate a habanero one time i didn't know
i didn't know i bought it i went it was
right it was when i first moved out of
the house it was like one of my first
supermarket shops
so my first my first apartment i had a a
cart overflowing and there was a bag of
a styrofoam thing of peppers you know
when you get it with the like it's
weighed and they have the plastic over
it like it's wrapped in a package and it
was like an orange a yellow a red a
green it was like it was really colorful
and i was like oh like i thought there
was sweet peppers and i said i bought it
i had it in my kitchen a couple days
later i i passed out i ripped open the
plastic i just took one and popped in
the mouth i didn't know it was a
habanero i don't i don't have
i don't have the constitution for it uh
when i eat wings i go through half a box
of tissues just wings
i couldn't i i was alone in my house i
had to bust out a gallon of milk and i
had to sip the milk for his it was like
dude it was
it
it went beyond burning yeah it starts to
make your body hurt yeah it hurts yeah
and
you start to choke
tearing uncontrollably nose running
uncontrollably you get flush you almost
feel like you're gonna pass out and it
doesn't go away the only little relief
you get is when the milk is first poured
into your mouth if you hold the milk in
your mouth it it overcomes the milk
eventually too turns it into more and i
and i couldn't believe it took so long
for the pain to go away from a habanero
that i it shocked me and i thought i was
going to call somebody so i think it
took no joke i think it took probably
about 15 minutes for me to get over one
habitat i've i've had i've had run-ins
with habaneros because i made i made
sausage in a i mean italian sausage and
peppers once and i added habanero to it
to spice it up and it was brutal but
pimp pulled up the fact
that ghost pepper is only six times
hotter than a habanero i thought it was
a lot more than that but that's like
eating six straight habaneros can you
put scoville sc
ov
shut up royce gobo
okay there we go rory school one of my
favorites rory scoville
okay
measures a million
it's okay this this is one million over
one million scoville yeah so i'm not
eating i'm eating something flavored
with it
you know do you ever hear like jalapeno
this is beyond this is there's a reason
there's a warning on the box the warning
continues uh
uh
keep out of the reach of children after
touching chip wash your hands with soap
and do not touch your eyes or other
sensitive areas oh i got a story for you
seek medical assistance should you
experience difficulty breathing yeah
fainting or extended nausea
i'm scared for you so i was in israel i
used to study when i was like in
seminary and i'd have these this uh
thing of
um uh
sunflower seeds big israeli sunflower
seeds and people come by and just eat
them without asking i didn't care for
that
so i was like to punish those people i
opened up some habaneros took out the
peppers just out the seeds just the
seeds slightly open up some sunflowers
that's the hard part that's the hot part
right that's the hot part stuck him in
there just like opened it a little bit
stuck him in there and left him and then
i had two things and if you asked i
would give you the proper sunflower
seeds and if you didn't ask you'll get
punished and did you
well what i didn't know is after i was
done preparing i went to pee and oh
yeah
i had a shower with my clothes on oh my
god
[Music]
yeah
too close to the sun i did the hottest
thing ever was there was a wings place
in lancaster pa and they had they had
attempted suicide wings and then suicide
suicide was the hottest and i put the
suicide wing to my mouth
and my lips immediately turned numb
yeah barely but i'm saying this
why do you order something with the word
suicide in it well because we all went
in college that's the point they want to
kill you yeah we went in college and it
was like it was like we got to try this
this is what this place is known for
a lot of times i'll get a thai person or
something where you order like thai
spicy like ooh you sure and they'll talk
me out of it and then something's like
no no go thai spicy man i can i can take
this like so okay so you have a leg up
though because you always you like spice
you eat spice i love it i like the i
like a minimal minimal heat but i'm a
complete baby when it comes to it so you
this will be interesting this will be
very interesting all right now we were
gonna add an element to the battle
where ari plants the chip inside this
bag of doritos so he doesn't even know
when he's going to eat it
but i'm wondering should he just eat it
well
i i'm going to i'm nervous about it i'm
only nervous on one thing what if that
chip breaks in there okay so here's what
i think i think we should call an
audible i think we should have ari just
eat the chip now and start the battle
and watch him try to battle if he eats
it now there's
there's no way we could do the battle
i'm excited for him to eat the chip but
i want him to watch the chance in person
that's yeah yeah yeah
i think we do the battle and then maybe
somewhere in the middle or to the end he
eats the chips and then watch the
chicken no no the chance happened before
the battle oh wait to see de rosa's come
up with some great no but but i think i
think he's not gonna be able to compete
with us if he eats that [ __ ] the point
that's where we sit at the top it's in
decision then that's hot ones i'll be
able to compete no no it's so hot once
can you imagine he he you could imagine
he wins with honey nut cheerios then
eats that and is fine with it we we
should we should retire the podcast
no no he's got to eat the whole point
was that he eats it during the battle oh
i just thought that he eats it like oh
yeah i guess that while he's while he's
eating yeah let's just have ahri eat the
chip and start the banana why is that
facing around one right it says round
one spicy punch round two scorpion sting
round three vision disrupter round four
guts slash round five here it is are
those the stages yeah i don't get it
it's it's got first of all great
marketing great branding
casket
yeah they need to do something to charge
15 bucks for a potato chip yeah you
should get a this is like a an album do
you know what that cost them do you know
what that cost them to sell one chip
probably 17 cents yeah it's got to be
well it sounds like is there multiple
chips in there no it's a single chip
it's a single chip challenge i'm gonna
i'm gonna ramp up i'm gonna have a
dorito okay and then i'm gonna you can
move on you got water you got milk got
water got milk okay that was terrible on
there
first we'll just start with the normal
doritos which has the spicy uh logo on
it a little bit no no that's just not
your chicken
don't make yourself a hero the uh all
right ready yeah
time for the battle
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you here we go all
right b-a-t-t-l-e
buds
did you have to institute that because
you legitimately were angry at each
other for like a week
we had one where it was like it was like
one it was like a real really terrible
fight like a real one and then it wasn't
you know i know it's not he doesn't
right and then he left and told me that
he spent the whole week in like a
downward spiral and he was walking
around his own house saying no matter
what happens
zolo
zolofortlover69 said i'm a lesbian and
even i picked the nut for the cereal
that's funny i like that oh that's a
good way to put it only a man who has
tidy whities would choose honey nut
heroes they don't know that we have a
guest
they have no idea they don't know so
yeah yeah
they'll know they'll only know when they
answer based on who they think you guys
took
yeah
yeah they do that too and who they want
and who they think we took and a lot of
times they're right
captain crunch is for landscapers who
like to chew rocks and have a weed
whacker in their mouth sorry for the
coughing everybody i'm getting over cold
the level of sugar in a cat and crunch
it's it's so it's a it's offensive it
you you feel the sugar you shouldn't
feel sugar but you can have one bowl and
just be done with it
let me tell you something captain crunch
is you know what i like i like captain
crunch regular and but when they add the
berries the two combined for salty sweet
a better yes a better taste than alone
and
they've stayed consistent with that
taste a lot of cereals like something
changes they don't taste as chem they
taste more chemically now i don't know
and i also love
how long captain crunch will keep that
crunch when submerged in milk you could
even wait a good like five six seven
minutes and you'll still get a decent
crunch out of it cheerios dude yeah
cheerios get soft within like a minute
or two and then you're just eating these
little like little discs that
break apart but you often eat cheers not
milk you never use cap crunch as a snack
food oh that's not true who would do
that i've done i've done that you
captain chris i go to a bag of cab
crusher i take a fistful yeah
i eat it like a bugle or something like
that like in your lunch like your mom
would put that in your life no but i've
been known to go open the box downstairs
and just throw some in my mouth and also
if you were my mom and you packed in my
lunch as my snack a bag of cheerios i
would leave school and come beat you
what a [ __ ] snack cheerios off of people
that are just getting teeth yeah they're
for people
there are for people that are just
losing all their teeth yeah
and they're they're good they that
softness you're right does serve you if
you don't have teeth yet you're just
like working around that's why the kids
get it because so they can just swallow
the rings whole
there's no oats in cap'n crunch you're
oatless it is confirmed by the way honey
churros is the nation's most popular
cereal honey nuts
but also pimp go back to that page honey
nut was not the first spin-off
which i find fascinating also said that
captain crunch was made
in order specifically to combat soggy
cereals you just had it you just said
yeah
cheerios first spin-off
uh wasn't in fact honey nut it was
actually cinnamon nut
which is rolled out which is which was
my favorite prostitute's name
which was rolled out in 1976 much like
myself
my mom rolled me out in 76 too and they
used to call me cinnamon nuts honey nut
cheerios used to also have actual nuts
which makes you wonder
what
what is representing the nuts now in the
cereal yeah do they have a taste uh when
did captain grunch come out
probably look after lady gaga crunch
with crunch berries right well i just
i'm just curious
because peanut butter crunch was the
first spin-off
oh i thought peanut butter crunch was
the crunch peanut butter i thought cam
crunch had that peanut butter taste
captain crunch original is just its own
little thing
do you know when they came out with a
donkey kong cereal it was actually
captain crunch and they were supposed to
be the barrels it was awesome because
they're almost barrels right now you had
marshmallow like mario's i think right
yeah i think so yeah um
corner no 63 corn and oat it does have
oat it does have okay so
1963 argument
was when the original came out well
before before hunting up but let's do
the berries the original was developed
to recall a recipe of brown sugar and
butter over rice
really that's what you guys are eating a
recreation of brown sugar and butter
there is this there is this mapley like
little hint to it 67. it came out that
long wow it came out 12 years before
honey nut
7900 yeah yeah wow
and then and then honey nut just lapped
them
just was like oh you know it is true it
is true
why do we think that honey nut cheers is
the number one selling cereal why what
attributes does it have you stay health
so parents like my parents who cared
about our health were like all right we
can let you guys splurge sweet wise but
this we're still it's part of a complete
breakfast it's yeah it's people think
it's somebody tweeted cheerios are good
for your are heart healthy it's like
they're only heart healthy because
they're not heart damaging they have the
no yeah they they put the heart on the
box actually oh yeah that's all and they
say low is your cholesterol i think too
low your cholesterol because you're not
eating more cholesterol that's what
they're selling you it's like snake oil
no it lowers your cholesterol that's
crazy you can't just say it lowers your
cholesterol in relation to eating a
snickers i think that's what it does
though i think it lowers your
cholesterol by way of not affecting your
cholesterol that's nuts
it's honey nuts
it says and i think it also says
[ __ ] i missed it
has been shown to lower bad cholesterol
as part of a heart-friendly diet yeah
it's part of a heart that's what you do
you can't have cap crunches part of a
heart-friendly diet no you cannot
absolutely absolutely yeah that's why
it's oats oats an easy first step to
lowering your cholesterol is having a
bowl of oatmeal or cold oat-based cereal
like cheerios
it gives you one to two grams of soluble
fiber but cow crunch is full of oats we
thought it has oats it has i don't know
it's as odd
can i ask you guys a question and this
is i'm supposed to be cheerios just so
you know that's how much it was an oats
wise cheerios cheerios really yeah yeah
that's how that's how old heavy it is
okay i've experienced this and then one
time um when i used to bartend a friend
of mine brought it up and i couldn't
believe it because i never said it out
loud and he said exactly what i said and
then we googled it and we found it
online and so i don't know if everyone
knows this
but sometimes for some reason when you
put cheerios in a bowl and milk after a
little while it smells like straight up
piss
i'm not joking it smells like a bowl of
urine i'm swear to god i swear to god
why do cheerios smell like piss put that
in
just put yeah it smells like piss i've
never known no way
why does my piece
yeah and then your piece smells like
cheerios too i pee sometimes and it
smells like cheerios i swear why does my
pee smell like cheerios
wow i don't eat cheerios often i do eat
sweets
well that's the question so here's the
answer yeah diabetes was my first lunch
cheerio smells like p or p smells like
cheerios just put that in and see what
it says
yeah it's it's everyone says it the
sweet odor is due to excess glucose in
your body is trying to flush out getting
treatment for diabetes is critical to
protecting your health
why did what did she risk
i've never noticed that see it thought
the stale stench
i still st i i i i'm surprised you would
even let cheerios last out so none of
you none of you have ever felt that grew
up with cheers that's my only cereal and
you just see it and it smelled like a
bowl of cheerios no but that's why
that's why the diabetes thing resonates
because people that have are diabetic
uh their pee a lot of the times smells
like sugary or cakey
this just smells like straights cheerios
i think it's just cheerios
not every time but it might look like
you've got a sugary smelling pea and
that's why the cheerios i haven't my pea
isn't smell let me make something
straight
my pee doesn't smell like cheerios in
ages but all right it's a thing that
everyone said listen to me if the guy
sound off in the comments and tell me if
you've ever experienced this don't lie
tell me if before i said it you've
thought it talked about it you heard it
or smelled it that cheerios in a bowl
left out will smell like piss piss or
will it make your piss vice versa no no
no no i'm not saying that your cheerios
makes you pee has nothing cheers has
nothing to do with the p
cheerios smells like pee and sometimes
the p smells like cheerios independent
of each other i'm gonna make a vote for
something yeah yeah i want you to eat
the chip hey everybody today's episode
is sponsored by honey if you don't know
what honey is imagine you are shopping
on one of your favorite sites when you
check out the honey button drops down
and all you have to do is click apply
coupons wait a few seconds honey
searches the coupons uh for that
particular site and if it finds a
working one you'll watch the prices drop
right there what did honey save you
money on clothes tech gadgets pizza how
much did you save you could save as much
i used it just recently to order flowers
i saved 30 bucks on flowers
and 30 bucks is significant right pimpy
oh yeah yeah i uh i just put it in my
browser it's there all the time you
forget about it and then when you check
out it just automatically populates it's
the easiest thing it's the best thing
i've done there's no reason not to do it
it's just you don't have to go searching
for the codes uh if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing out on free savings it's
literally free and installs in a few
seconds and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a salad and supporting
this podcast get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
tastebuds that's joinhoney.com taste
buds what's up guys want to talk to you
about hellofresh our fave with
hellofresh you get fresh pre-measured
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
trips to the grocery store and count on
the hellofresh to make home cooking easy
fun and affordable that's why it's
america's number one meal kit with
options like quick and easy meals low
prep one pan and 10 to 15 minute meals
that's time cut down spending and
cooking and cleaning you give back to
your family or yourself if you don't
like your family hellofresh offers the
flexibility you need to easily customize
your order on the app within minutes
change your delivery day change your
food preferences the plan size or skip a
week whenever you want uh you know we
started using it because they became a
sponsor of the podcast and now i don't
know what it was like having without it
i use it all the time i don't cook and
now i cook i'm addicted to it right yeah
yeah it makes it fun because you feel
like you have the guidance you need i
don't go in the kitchen if i don't have
someone there that knows what they're
doing so this helps um go to
hellofresh.com
tastebuds14 and use codes tastebuds14
tastebuds 14 for up to 14 free meals
including free shipping you guys know
this one we talk about all time best
deal in the biz uh that's
hellofresh.com
tastebuds one for use
codetastebuds14
for up to 14 free meals that's going to
include free shipping uh hellofresh
america's number one meal kit yeah yeah
i want you to eat the chip okay i want
you to eat the chip cause i want to
really get into the real part of the
battle okay what's the real part of the
battle we're gonna really start talking
about the attributes of captain crunch
with crunch berries okay and why it
smokes i i don't think he should eat
that
not now because i think that it's going
to throw the episode away i think we
should at least get
halfway through we're halfway halfway
through what time what time you got
we're at 30 minutes what is your sense
of time i'm sorry i'm having fun all
right here we go
but we didn't really battle i also want
to know we're going to battle now he's
going to eat the chip i think that i
think all all battles are off the second
he chews into that
it doesn't matter what you think what's
going to happen he would agree to
and he's going to do it now okay this
was the deal when i eat it and i just go
oh man that's that's for real spicy wow
okay we don't know let's stop
speculating
i will be in awe
shock at all thank you that's a real
answer all right
i i believe in ari he's got this all
right if you're not if you're listening
and not watching ari's putting on a
rubber kitchen glove yeah that i had in
my i had in my in my kitchen it's
covered in chemicals
it's a blue glove that's covered in
yellow chemicals it's definitely not
designed to only be on yeah yeah it's so
much chemicals i looked at it and i was
like oh they have like a green like a
yellow design on it
i've said for years you're the most
lunatic person i know i will not be
surprised if you eat this and laugh
i i also won't be surprised if you eat
it and it's horrible but you are the
crazy person that would eat it you know
what i mean i will tell you i have right
now i swear i have true fear true fear
yeah he's gonna be fine would you stop i
know he's not children do this on the
internet for christ's sake
i know
i'm not
i'm not fearing that he's gonna die i
know he's gonna be [ __ ] i fear that
he's gonna be like literally like in
super super super pain like you
shouldn't do it that'll be great for the
podcast if i died you air this episode
oh yeah oh for legal reasons oh my gosh
look at the colors it's a pay-per-view
dark it's a pay-per-view it is dark yeah
it's paper yeah
wow compared to what dorito the color is
it's like far different oh my god dude
oh my god it's like blue corn
yeah
dude
before you take it yeah yeah yeah just
let's go through
what you think is going to happen to you
you know what i should have some you
know cheerios here to douse whatever
pain i have there's a mistake on my part
i think i'm it's gonna start i'm gonna
be like this is nothing this is moronic
of course anyone then i'll be like oh
there it is
i'm it's definitely going to be hotter
than like what i was eating with him
habanero chips but
do you think you'll be able to be
already with the podcast yeah you'll
think you'll be able to speak to us and
perform and you think you'll be able to
put up a defense for honey nut cheerios
yeah in the face of the pain
why did you bring up the cholula
i wouldn't even put it on it because i
don't want to i don't want to take away
the heat oh you think it'll douse it my
friend said to me once i was putting
ketchup on on on french fries he goes
are you one of those people who thinks
putting cold ketchup on french fries
makes it less hot and i was like no
but
yeah it definitely does i never heard of
that genius yeah genius out of the
fridge yeah
it doesn't give you a direction
because it's like ah oh okay eat the
entire chip here we go ready uh hold i
do like that they didn't make it too big
that's that's nice what do you think
your bowel movement's gonna be like same
as always disgusting
all right ready you're gonna be throwing
heat too just eat the whole chip now
you're gonna need something eat the
entire chip it's gonna be hot coming out
eat the entire chip wait as long as
possible before eating or drinking
anything post your reaction on social
media
first of all that's the challenge i
won't post on social media because you
don't control me
okay
that being said this will be an hour
special on social media
just eat the whole chip
that's ghost pepper i can smell it
really can we smell it yeah yeah yeah
i can buy nope nope
hold on pass that down just pass it down
okay
really
yeah that's that's that's thick
oh that is a s it's like a that's a musk
musty mustache so eat the whole chip
and then we'll start talking about honey
nut cheerios yeah yeah
come on can you need any more questions
just don't spill it don't don't like
spill milk and [ __ ] yeah i don't know if
you're gonna be frantic this is what he
says he's worried about his well-being
not more than his carpet
don't spill the milk i won't spill it
but if i do spill it you can't apologies
i care about both i he might be flailing
he's not gonna fail i watched a man do
this on the wheel of his car
marshall man what i watched the guy do
this on youtube behind the wheel of his
car and how was he he was fine he was
just like he was like punching the
steering wheel like god damn but like he
didn't he was fine
just punch to rosa's face oh yeah
i'm so mad
oh my god
that's not the whole chip which stale
get the piece
i gotta get that are you feeling it yet
before it doesn't count
no no don't start come on don't push it
he finished the last big bite with a
bunch of cholula
to rub it in our faces
all right now it's got it's got to be
kicking that glove off so you don't burn
your face
keep it inside out
okay it is beginning
oh my god so
anyway the taste was good the taste
itself was good oh my god you look wait
you already you already look like you're
gonna die you look like you're gonna die
um your eyes are bulging out of your
head the pressure of it was a problem
it was a bit stale but
not so still you couldn't do it
listen dude oh it lights up your mouth
honey nut cheerios
so the bee versus the captain as far as
mascots go okay
yeah he ain't getting nowhere near that
character first of all
military stuff right away
if the bee goes away we're done as a
society in the world
that is a really good in distress he
made that point
yeah well look the beat is lame as all
[ __ ] nobody beats the captain yeah the
captain he's got the hat that's a huge
stash the cab [ __ ] ruined the
environment by drinking on the sm valdez
the bee has never done anything wrong
with this look at the captain he looks
like a good time charlie and a class act
this is and also too with crunch berries
you're getting you're getting the oats
the odiness of the crunch oh my god
if you're listening if you're listening
you're gonna have to come check out the
youtube uh episode but tears are
streaming down his face it is on the
back of the top it's moved around now i
might say my saliva is like
oh
he has not taken a sip of water or milk
yet that is why what is it we didn't
time it
[ __ ] all right it's 3 10. it's 3 10
right now what does that mean
it means like he's now you you've
already gone like three minutes without
him holding himself in a hug and
shivering
a little it does do a thing okay
damn it's working away around the mouth
all right so let me read the steps those
steps
spicy are you regretting it no i'm not
regretting it okay
okay i think i'm in that stage
vision disrupter maybe one of my tears
tearing up starts
i mean that happened immediately and
then gut slash
how long oh my god are you might throw
up no i'm not gonna throw it oh cause
you're going oh
it's just like if you want to get it out
of the mouth
but there's nowhere to breathe i i am so
impressed that he's not drinking
anything yeah
yeah oh man this is incredible you don't
look do you need tissues
like most jews i stay properly hydrated
throughout the day
dude it's giving you like it's giving
you like a uh anjana is that a thing
that i might get yeah oh yeah oh yeah
it's giving you like a throaty like
catholic
you're gonna have hot holes all around i
don't wanna like swallow on it oh yeah
dude this thing coming out is gonna be
brutal okay
oh this is starting to pass no that
quickly i think it's starting to pass
that quickly ugh
the nose running i don't want to touch
my hands too much yeah i got tissues oh
perfect
oh my god
there's something crumbs i don't want to
get what i was going to say was is the
odiness of the captain crunch meeting
the berry fruitful fullness is you can't
you can't touch that with a honey nut
cheerio how do you know cheers
and say that again
the breeze in captain crunch crunch is
better better and why it's the best
cereal it's the one of the only cereals
where you're getting the fruitiness of
the berry and then the oatiness of the
crunch very few cereals meet a sort of
earthy flavor against a fruity flavor
it's usually all fruit or all chocolate
right or
are all oat yeah too much going on real
what's going on with all those flavors i
disagree and stuff like that whereas the
honey nut cheerio you have it all in one
small compact thing it's a glaze it's a
glazed donut whereas we were talking
about one of those voodoo doughnuts
where you have a [ __ ]
muffin on top of the doughnut and bacon
or something like that you're going too
far do you mean the most famous donut on
the planet the one where i said can i
get a t-shirt and the girl goes it's all
the way upstairs
are you mad at that or you just is
it's all the way upstairs and i just
watched was it in l.a please tell me
that was important is this the chip
talking right now yeah even better like
only in l.a or portland with somebody
like that they can't be bothered what
they can't be bothered in portland can i
tell you what i like to do with uh
captain crunch with berries
i think the opposite i think it's a
strength that there is both berry and
regular cap and crunch because i with
each spoonful can choose the ratio of of
of crunch to bury and i could do you
could save four berries with two and get
a very heavy uh spoonful
on all marshmallow oh no you don't have
marriage yeah all berry spoonful i i i
decide i ration
what i want and a lot of times i'll save
a shitload of berries for the end and
i'll let the berries turn that milk blue
baby and i'll drink that berry milk the
purple is not as good in a high nut
cherry purple yeah but you do get if
you're in a health conscious family that
would uh afford a children honey nachos
you get chopped up strawberries and
chopped up bananas uh and then you can
choose what to eat well you're breaking
a rule we have on this podcast which is
uh enhancement it's generally served
that way but you you that's an
enhancement that's that's the food not
standing on its own
[Music]
but i will say this
captain christopher contributions it's
like
first let me give that to you i'll even
give it to you there's no more fun box
on earth first of all that's true second
of all it's like dude i get a box of
[ __ ] i have to stop myself from reading
the whole box in one sitting i do too
and let me tell you something i flip it
to the side i do the maze i flip it to
the other side i do the word games i
flip on the back i read that whole thing
it's a fun box it's also one of the
series that i think used to give you a
prize cheerios as a whole never bothered
at all and even knowing that children
eat they never bothered to give you a
prize they never give you a prize it's
just another box of cheerios sometimes
they tried a [ __ ] thing like hey cut
it out cut the box out in the back and
color it some [ __ ] yeah i'll tell you
one of my favorite thrift store shirts
of all time which is a yellow shirt that
said cheerios on it
people that is iconic that is iconic no
one we don't represent other countries
when we go to other countries they go do
you have cap'n crunch where you're from
no
cheerios oh you're known it's american
pimp do me a favor
google the guy
and wiki and then google captain let's
get their backstories yeah where did
they come from what's the bee's name
he's got a name for the honey anybody
know the bee's name that's a good
question uh fuzzy b i think shut it out
shout it out right now buzz the beast
want to talk to you about another one of
our faves babel learning a new language
can feel intimidating when i first
decided to learn spanish because i am
spanish i was worried about the level of
difficulty i live with my grandparents
though and they were conversation i was
conversational in spanish at one time
really forgot it was like 25 years ago
completely forgotten when i was studying
in high school and happened to live with
my spanish grandparents forgot it all
i've been using babel to get it back
it's kind of fun um let's see
thanks to babel the number one selling
language learning app the whole process
was addictively fun fast and easy that's
true true true whether you want to learn
a new language for an upcoming trip or
brush up on what you knew engage in a
new hobby babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons for real real world use
and that's what i like about the most
guys it's not like you're sitting down
studying they make it fun it's quick
it's easy they really pinpoint things
that you need to do and they make it
very amenable it's 15 minute lessons
other language apps use ai for the
lesson plans but babel was created by
over 100 language experts you can choose
from 14 different languages spanish
french italian german etc
and they have a speech recognition
technology that helps improve your
pronunciation and accent because of
course when i learned in school i was
like yo tango la biblioteca and i had
none of that flair it helps you with the
flare uh right now when you purchase
three month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use promo code
tastebuds that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code taste buds
babble
language for life what's up guys want to
talk to you about overland because i
love comfort i love luxury and these are
amazing slippers i just got my pair they
are sheepskin they're brown they're
suede they're firm on the bottom i wear
them in the house i feel like i'm
walking on air if you've listened to
this podcast you know that i think
there's things that you should spend
your money on and bedding and footwear
are two of the main things
overland is a family-owned american
heritage brand that's put comfort and
quality first for 50 years over 50 years
they offer outerwear and accessories and
home decor made from sustainable natural
fibers like sheepskin leather and wool
overland uses expert craftsmanship to
pair the highest quality merino
sheepskin that's what i have i slide my
foot into that thing it feels like i'm
putting my foot into a sheep which is
naturally in a good way
which is naturally moisture wicking
temperature regulating and antimicrobial
with supportive memory foam midsoles in
order to make slippers that feel better
and wear better for longer i'm telling
you i rock these things all day every
day so don't wait another day to slip
into something way more comfortable get
the best highest quality sheepskin
slippers on the market at overland.com
taste buds you'll get free shipping and
free returns and i recommend you go
today because these slippers are so
beloved that they're known to sell out
that is true the first pair that i chose
was sold out i had to go with the second
pair that's overland.com tastebuds
overland.com
tastebuds
let's let's let's let's talk about it
why are honey nut cheerios healthy
we talked about that wait yeah let's
just go i want to know about buzzfeed i
will believe they're healthy when i i
mean that's an outrageous claim to me i
just don't even understand
i can't believe how overrated this chip
is if you go to the are you the actual
page yeah
he's already passed it no you're done
yeah
it's on its way down oh you got to be
kidding me what a disappointment with
the key family
it's been you're not getting your guts
ripped out phase four or something i do
feel it a little bit my stomach
but just a little
oh wow and you didn't drink to drink
anything drink before you had a million
scovilles just now a million scovilles
plus
yeah i was blown away dude i don't know
what's going to do when it hits my like
stomach stomach but uh yeah it can't be
in the in the main stomach area yet
right it's still going through your
intestine no it's going through your
hit your stomach first really it goes
from stomach so you're saying it's in
the stomach right now one chip child
because you guys can't afford what
happens with food it goes to your
stomach yeah but when when when when
does it run away it's sushi eat it you
swallow something it's in your stomach
yeah
i mean my words would work its way down
but i have no idea yeah so uh the
intestine large small that's that comes
after the stomach interesting
or stomach didn't remember seinfeld you
got your tube in your circle but that's
this yeah yeah yeah yeah
well it's already in there i can't
believe this
that's wild yeah an overrated show i
definitely got the sweat i mean if i
would have done that though it would not
have been the same it did make you cry
it may be crying in a good way it was
tasty for sure
it tasted good oh yeah i've got a little
stale i do i can't understate the the
disappointment i have it's a steel chip
who knows how long this lady that gave
it to sal had it i mean look you know
she would have had it from years
all right or not years but yeah so
there's a date on the package of the box
um yeah maybe
it's food i'm sure it has to have one
all right here we go here we go here we
go the date the statesman best buy those
are the
0208 2022 oh wow so according to them it
is well within not still time maybe but
maybe it's not stale maybe the pepper
has an effect on the chip that makes it
like the changes the concealer oh maybe
maybe it's soaked it in yeah pocky more
like aki es la champion there you go
brought the whole family together there
was nobody that outlier nobody doesn't
like honey nut cheerios whereas some
people you go to a [ __ ] cat and
crunch and you're like that's too much
for me no thanks oh that's a good point
i will give you i will give you you go
to a cabin and go like oh i only bought
honey no cheerios no one's gonna go i
just won't have cereal then and i would
have very good point
can you read that can you read about the
be there buddy
me yeah oh sorry honey nut cheerios
mascot is an anthropomorphic bee
designed for the first commercials by
dean yeagel
uh the bee did not have a name until
2000 when christine tong a fifth grade
student from coolidge texas won a
national contest
dubbing him buzz b wow
several actors were avoided provided the
voice of buzz most notably billy west
what about him does he have a story
really
is batman
billy west was no billy west is uh is uh
if you ever saw um
he's uh future fry f on futurama oh yeah
he was wearing the comedy scene and he's
uh he wished to be on stern all the time
he used to do uh
uh larry from the stooges on stern
oh the song oh he's red and stimpy too
but
that's the characters where's the
captain
here's why mrs did that right there in
the 1980s captain's main average
adversaries were the soggies i remember
alien creatures resembling blobs of milk
whose goal was to make everything on
earth soggy who would what what
i'm glad this came up right now i'm glad
this came up right now because everybody
always complains about the one disc i
was here with captain crunch is it's so
hard in the roof of your mouth no it
keeps the crunch that's the point of
this here that's
people will say you get sliced up like
razor blades but you got to know how to
eat it yeah you can't just throw it in
and just roast it it can't just hit the
roof of your mouth you're asking for
trouble what is what you sound like is
when you're like hey i think i'm going
to go work out i'm going to get in shape
a good workout and then all your
workouts go oh no you're doing relax and
try you shouldn't have done that right
you told me to work out and now you're
saying i didn't do it right and that's
why i'm getting injured no but this is
different this is something this is an
innate ability to chew and swallow kids
come out sucking already immediately
by going to the gym i need to ask my
friends how to do this you don't know
how to put a crunch between your two
teeth and use your teeth you're gonna
let it hit the roof of your mouth that's
you if you if you write in the comments
that it slices up you you're the problem
you're the problem
so wait a minute just wait a minute and
then have the perfect crunch when you
get that slight sog on a captain crunch
the slight sog where just the outside
gives and then the inside still has the
pop and the crunch
that's unbelievable man it's
you're banging on all cylinders at that
point and i tell you some people like
that you know that little little like
kind of slimy coating that it might get
which doesn't sound appetizing i
actually like it yeah it adds to the
texture and the taste experience i don't
i don't i don't argue i think that
captain crunch goes through several
phases in that bowl and i think every
phase is wonderful
i think honey nut cheerios is a great
cereal much like you need to put a box
of something in a hotel lobby that's not
going to make anybody work mad
you don't want to rub it rub any
feathers the wrong way at the in in the
best western you put honey nut cheerios
out it's the independent of politics no
one cares but
yellow let's be honest if if you have
20 cereals there and you say pick one
i'm always going for the captain crunch
with berries okay but that's like saying
if you have all these soups no one's
gonna go for chicken noodle because it's
like you can get it all the time so
obviously when you have an option to get
a split pea and ham you're like oh let
me try this for once okay so you're
saying are you saying honey nut cheerios
is the chicken noodle soup of cereal
everybody loves it but when you have an
option for something else you go for
something else now i hate it because i
hate chicken noodle soup of course you
do i hate it it sucks i mean you you
you're such a great when you see the
[ __ ] when i'm on instagram i see oh
it's this versus this i'm like well i
know derosa
is obviously argumentative for no reason
i thought star wars episode one was
better than the original green because
the cinematographer came back from my
next episode is luke skywalker vs han
solo tune in folks yeah yeah yeah luke
skywalker versus han solo that's our
next episode oh really
like what they taste like some sort of
star wars i'm like wait i thought one
day no no no
uh let's go to the phones
uh
he goes i would do skywalker solo i
gotta take solo i thought about it for a
moment i said i get what you're saying
he's the bad boy
luke is the center of the universe bro
the worst actor in the history of movies
no mark hamill is not he was terrible no
he's not that's not sidetracked that's
that's right would you like to sit in
yeah you can sit if you want i'll sit
and just do this in the back
sit in sit in him judge it
all right all right let's go to the
phones we got to wrap this up phony
cholesterol lowering tasteless garbage
versus a childhood memory forever bound
by the sweet taste of berries i like
captain crunch all day
that might be the winning tweet not
phony not funny the first word it's not
phony cholesterol although it tastes
good not phony it's real it lowers
cholesterol no it doesn't
it doesn't let me tell you something
i've had elevated cholesterol the last
three times i had blood work done yeah i
said to my doctor what should i do he
didn't everyone said eat cheerios
he he writes on the pants he's like go
to cvs not to the pharmacy yeah
that's because he's talking to you his
first like drink less than seven weeks
bring this to vernon who's that the
pharmacist no he's the kid that stops
the series
honey cheerios protection you gotta go
see the general who's that general mills
[Laughter]
what to do honey nut cheerios is that
friend who's always honest even when you
don't want it it's honey and nuts
captain crunch is the unnecessarily
vague friend who never gives you a
straight answer i know what i'm getting
with honey nut cheerios yeah what the
[ __ ] is oh come on crunch is is is your
friend who's gonna sister at your
wedding
that's not don't speak like the cat the
captain like that i'll take the razor
blade cuts on the roof of my mouth while
he kept the crunch over the absolute
flavor to avoid honey nut cheerios all
day every day how can we flavor devoid
when it's a giant step up from regular
cheerios honey that is good if the only
alternative is a pack of menthol
cigarettes that's the winner let's give
it to this one that's our winner austin
wins follow us in aka canada 2016 on
twitter uh let's go to the top pimp what
do we got let's refresh first of all and
get a tally i can't believe how i when i
was by the way trying to play the heel a
little bit i thought it would hurt me
more great work plugs that's a fresh
milk you didn't even sip water yet
didn't even set water that's
unbelievable do your plugs you've earned
them sir thank you very much uh in
november i'll be in uh tampa or in
orlando at the improv respectively and
then on december i'll be in oklahoma
city uh the boston at the wilbur on
december 9th and san antonio get tickets
at reshaffir dot you're going to be at
the wilbury's 79th december 9th i'm
going to be at the chevrolet which is
like 20 minutes away december 10th
are you gonna you have something the
next day you want to stay
maybe i was thinking of taking off and
flying to some country also what are you
doing in orlando because i'm doing uh no
which one's close i'm doing four louder
than west palm any of those close
no
middle middle temperature talk about
boston yeah yeah okay uh thank you joey
roses the brick and mortar the shop the
real deal uh this we're a couple we're
recording a little pre here so it
actually might be out when this episode
drops we might that might be our opening
week
i'm sorry i'll tell you what data says
this is coming out november 8th november
8th we should be open right now
hopefully we didn't hit anything what's
the address babe 174 rivington street in
the east village or i'm sorry the lower
east side of new york city
uh come by we're open initially
tuesday through saturday all day uh
serving the sandwiches until we close at
night
cheap booze you couldn't come a great
time
with me and and okay and silver because
the opening weekend is gonna be
september well well
it's funny it's not an exact science
opening
uh-oh hold on a second
oh my god a second you get in the guts i
don't know where that came
i know i i'm sorry i wanted to be there
with you this is uh it's a tricky
business so excited for the bar uh
what's it called joey roses
uh we're opening soon and then also 20
uh i'll plug those dates later the other
podcast is we'll see you in hell
um uh with patrick walsh only on patreon
at patreon.com wsyihpodcast
and i'll see you at skankfest
did it happen yet it happened it's
happening
what a fun time it was
all right today being november 8th uh
thanks for everyone who came out to
durham on the tournament so uh in four
days i'll be at the fort lauderdale
improv for the weekend uh december 4th
and 5th i'll be at the west palm beach
improv boston december 10th at the
chevrolet theater atlantic city december
11th at the borgata events center i'm so
excited about those two shows uh and
then come see me and chrissy d the week
between christmas and new year's eve
dallas on the 26th san antonio on the
27th houston on the 28th st louis on the
29th columbus on the 30th and celebrate
new year's eve with us in cincinnati on
the 31st all tickets available at
savilecountcomedy.com follow me on
socials which i never say at several
counter at volcano and what else
that's it so so we're going to go to the
polls now
what do we do is
there's a reason we did all the plugs is
now that we see who won whoever won this
is all that happens now okay i'm hoping
okay go ahead whoever won
has to say
no i still love you babe and then you
have to say i love you too and that's it
that's how it ends
okay whoever won
i i think the only chance i have is that
people remember
childhood and more children ate my shoes
you got a lot of pro
acting crunches childhood too man i
don't i don't think you get the
chocolate everybody got once you go into
that level of sugar cereal you split it
up between fruit loops cap and
charms the frankenstein ones and all you
know blueberries i never ate honey nut
cherries as a child i think you got
better better shot with the adults you
grew up in an orphanage of course they
were they could give you a high level of
cereal like that they gave
we need actual bees
actually my dad and stepmom only bought
honey nut cheerios like that that was
the main thing
okay we have probably at this point
close to like 13 000 votes or something
like that okay and uh this is the humble
pie segment so drum roll what do you got
to say if you win if you lose if you win
if you win you go i still love you and
if you lose i still love you and then
the other person goes i love you too
that's it okay i think we reversed that
but anyway if you win if you lose you
say i still love you no no if you win i
still love you because you take the guy
in you're defeated but don't worry about
it yeah you're not awesome i thought it
was the other way around i don't when
you lose so whatever derosa says 50
episodes yeah
15.
but i still love you like because i lost
i still love you no
back me up it's like i want it's like
hey don't worry i'm going with derozan
he's right because the person who wins
is always the one to say that and the
other person's like i love you too
yeah you're right yeah yeah all right
well this is uh
the drum roll come on
pin puts up the percentages right now
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
honey nut cheerios takes it
by point
seven percent holy 50.7
to
49.3 which is actually rematch territory
it's it's it's
elections it would be recount wait a
minute you just walked in here as the
first guest yeah won the battle
of the people and ate the chip
my god you probably you might be our new
mascot yeah
can you make me into a bee yeah
yeah oh
guys
get his head on that honeybee
send it in
i want to thank all the viewers in
advance for uh all the uh comments that
will be under this episode saying please
let ari replace derosa on the show
that'll be a lot of fun it's gonna be a
lot of laughs okay
wow this i mean this is an amazing
battle amazing it was amazing i want you
guys to know that even though i was
right like
i still love you guys
we still love you too
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking tastebuds